oh all the hard life of a youtuber I've
been filming all day can you tell us
but I need a video for tomorrow and I
don't have one yet so I thought we'd
play some horror games like the good old
days cuz it's so late anyway
[Music]
I worked so hard I know I am a hard work
oh but the things I do for my hands what
is wrong with me you can tell I'm tired
it's not I'm not funny I'm just [ __ ]
annoying okay let's play this game
Michael has selected these games for me
thank you Romanian he says [ __ ] off can
you believe that guy the joy of
creations Michael I played this game
there are all the levels I'm told by
Romanian well let's check it out
Oh didn't you miss when Pete if I used
to play horror games let epic jump scare
faces okay actually you know what this
looks cool oh I'll play it oh oh oh well
this looks awesome
and it's good voice acting like I'm
jogging legs
we got a thumb action to destroy I got
to destroy that clown whoa what oh wow
she says bunnies like one day I'll sex
him and he doesn't like he doesn't what
ah Shh
[ __ ] I'm scared I'm legit scare this
doesn't happen very often let's use this
to our advantage could it be because I'm
playing during the night Hey okay let's
just be careful Jesus look at my hand I
got Parkinson's all the sudden oh my god
no I hear him oh oh it's coming here
Timmy do something okay I don't
well done
[ __ ] that you know what I need I need
something to calm down I need something
to feel better I know my favorite videos
people eating cereal it always comes
from me down it's like ASMR for me
all right I think I'm ready for round
two
oh [ __ ] my dog my Snoop Dogg get it dog
I said why I gotta find okay here we go
damaged pipes acquire hammer damaged
pipes acquire a lighter get back to me
easy easy we got this you're with me on
this one
cuz we're gonna do fine mark that T is
way too hard to drink it's not supposed
to steam like that you're gonna burn
your tongue it's this a branded video I
don't understand I don't can someone
explain who'll it's a candle for
breakfast don't don't make me that face
mark I think that one bothers me most
about this video is that he lit a candle
because guys don't lit candles it's
forbidden just you can't do that what
are you gonna do next stare at a banana
oh all right I'm ready for more now this
game is clearly way too [ __ ] hard for
me okay okay I just gotta hide here we
go nice just take it nice and [ __ ]
easy mate all right
he just [ __ ] stupid
you are close why am I so bad at video
games if Marcel was here right now she'd
merely if I couldn't spit in my face
Pitts yes sir you say good game I break
up with you I know my tip please I what
why is this my life what am I doing
wrong
can you help me can you help me please
clearly I need some [ __ ] help hey
this looks different
oh my god it's just like the game oh oh
I got it I got the hammer
I did something hell yeah oh damn it
alright so according to her damage stuff
pops
demo stuff ah I've seen a [ __ ] ton of
pipes this is easy this is easy
BIP BIP it there's a pipe there's a pipe
alright so damn we can do this are you
with me right now I got a great feeling
[ __ ] I just walked in circles me
I'm ready for more ah my Syria wonderful
I get it now
I got it what can I say you converted me
Romanian what's the next game he said
this one now what the [ __ ] is is oh I
get it it's not for Jesus what [ __ ] whoa
Oh leave [ __ ]
man my Cyril just flew out on my bot man
he says you know you know not that one
not that one I'm not not doing now I'm
not doing huh
what is happening what is wrong how did
this happen I think this is probably my
favorite channel on YouTube he sits and
smiles
[Music]
he sits and smiles
for four [ __ ] Jesus hours oh my god
Benjamin Bennett 249 part 200 oh [ __ ]
Jesus [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
whoa this is terrifying what does whoa
oh that is not okay
why is it over here all right well the
game is over here for some reason some
I'm not ignoring you I'm just at the
game is tool I'm getting too old for
this man I'm looking I'm not a calm down
it's okay hey hey don't make my face
no I have three 300 timers chicken
timing Oh in the woods this is really
weird
all right hey I got that thing liking
that I hate oh I can't see all right I'm
it slender it's not it's slender I got I
get I got you
you just need eight more and more and
then I can go home and oh no you saw me
[Music]
you weren't supposed to see that
hello there oh it's amazing
you know what it's late I'll play one of
these properly another time but I I'm
really tired and I just want to go to I
want to go to sleep now
but first I'm probably gonna I'm gonna
probably gonna go home you have a quick
wank watch this video and then have
another one so thank you for watching I
appreciate that I hope you had fun and I
I did I good good a little scare got me
did I spoke you leave a like if we spook
you and I'll see your breath oh it hurts
my heart
I'm does scare me
[Music]